i'm tess pearson and i'm gay
uh cool you want fries or onion rings
with that number four prize please
i know we're going to be exploring more
of tess's storyline this season and that
has been teased to us so what can you
tell me
about season five and tessa's journey
tess is
growing up and i'm super excited for you
guys to see her she's
getting older i think that she's finally
forming her own identity in this season
figuring out who she is and i'm really
excited for you guys to see
who she is tess had such an incredible
moment in the series where
she came out i think i might like girls
what kind of response did you get from
that storyline from the lgbtq plus
community
it was it was such a good response like
words can describe how happy like me and
my family were
and i would get dms all the time from um
just children or just people in general
saying that they wish
they had a person like tess on their tv
screen
when they were growing up a beautiful
young girl jammed me
i'm in her mom too and they were saying
how not only did
tess help um the daughter but it helped
her mom
and i thought that was really cool as
well because it's not
only helping the kids or these people
it's helping parents
understand their children and i think
that's so important we love you
no matter what okay tell me what have
you
learned about the lgbtq plus community
through playing tess what i've learned
is um how this world
can just not be accepting and i think
that's what
broke my heart and that's what i always
kept in the back of my mind when i would
play scenes with tess especially the
scene that she came out
so like leading up to that scene i was
reading lots of stories
of just some incredible young people who
kind of had a similar story and they
were afraid
that they were going to get accepted by
their family or by people that's
something that nobody should worry about
and i think that's like the main thing
that really broke my heart it really
saddened me that
people have to almost they have to hide
who they are because they think they're
not going to get accepted
by people they don't even know that's
like this society can be super this side
needs to fall back and just stay
and be who you are and just worry about
yourself
at the end of season four of course
there is a rift
in the family your dad and your uncle
kevin had quite the falling
out hand to god randall the worst thing
that ever happened to me was the day
they brought you home
where do you think tess wants to see
that relationship go test i believe
definitely wants this problem to be
solved because she has a very close
relationship with her uncle kevin
just leave it alone okay tess he's my
uncle
and i'm close with him and i have a
right to know what's going on
because her uncle one accepts her and is
there for her
and not only like it was like accepting
her but was just there for her
and wanted to talk to her and helped her
through it i haven't come out at school
yet
so i could post nothing and be left out
or i can post the truth i have a crush
on zendaya
well it's also family at the end of the
day nobody likes family drama because it
tears family apart
and i'm i'm definitely one that's just
like i don't like it so i think that's
the same for tess
she wanted to be solved and jonathan
wants it to be solved
fast because she wants to talk to
chronicle and she wants her uncle to
come over
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos